Hello, my name's Trevor Nall.
I am married to Cheryl Nall,
and we have four children, Paige, Seth, Anna, and Olivia.
We've been at Henderson Hills since 2008 when we moved
to Edmond from Owosso, Oklahoma.
And, uh, we have enjoyed every moment of it.
It's been a season of healing, it's been a season
of growing, and it has been a season of serving
and caring, uh, for the ones that are closest to us.
I wanted to give you a little bit of history, uh, for me
and tell you the testimony of what God has done
and is doing in my life and in our family's life.
My family's from southwestern Oklahoma.
Originally my father from Sentinel, Oklahoma,
my mother from Altus.
I was born in Lawton, raised all over western Oklahoma,
from Lawton to Ponca City
and Ponca City back to Lawton, to Oklahoma City,
and eventually,
ultimately graduated from Woodward High School.
Um, I have a little bit of a running joke.
I went to six different elementary schools in seven years,
and, uh, no, I, I did not get kicked out of any of them.
It so happened that my father was in community banking
and, uh, if you're in community banking, you know
that sooner or later you get promoted up to a position
where the person in the seat ahead of you, in
that other position that you might get,
has their name on the building.
And in those cases, when you get the next
position professionally in community banking, you get
to move to a new bank.
And we did so frequently, uh, gave me a great appreciation
for new places and new people gave me an ability to, uh,
meet and, uh, be acquainted with a great deal of people.
Um, and I very much appreciate the experience
that I had from that
and have from that all that time
and all those different places.
Um, my parents were diligent to raise my brother
and I in the church, uh, from Lawton at First Baptist
to Second Baptist in Ponca.
And then once we got to Oklahoma City,
to Highland Hills Baptist Church
and on, we were in church every Sunday morning,
every Sunday evening, every Wednesday evening.
And, um, that is where God began to change
me, to teach me about him, to let me know who he is.
Um, it wasn't until Hinders,
or sorry, until Highland Hills that, uh, I came
to know the Lord, though, uh, we at that point were getting
to go to Music makers, which was a program
that the Southern Baptist had at Falls Creek
for younger children.
It wasn't Falls Creek as the, uh, youth might call it,
but it was music makers where, uh, hundreds of kids
around the state would gather together for a week
and we would learn music
and then we would be, uh, bust to Oklahoma City,
to the Cox Convention Center
where we would share the gospel news in music
before our parents and friends
and family, uh, that came to pick us up from camp that week.
And it was at Music Makers while I was at Highland Hills,
that I knew that I needed a savior.
Um, that's a difficult thing
because all my life to that point,
I'd been told that I was a good boy.
And what we know is
that good boys have a very difficult time understanding
that they're not really good
and they need something more than who they are.
What we know is that the most difficult person
to be saved is the person that doesn't believe
that they need to be saved.
But it was at music makers at Falls Creek that God
touched me to know that I needed a savior.
However, when I compared what was in my heart
and motives, I knew I couldn't choose him.
So he had to do a work in me, something I didn't understand.
For many, many years later, we went from Highland Hills
to Spring Creek Baptist.
In Northern Northwest OKC.
We went from there to Cherokee Hills Baptist Church in, uh,
war Acres, and then on to First Baptist Church.
Um, at Cherokee Hills, though, is
where I was first really confronted with the fact that, uh,
what I knew of God was limited.
I had peers and older kids
that were in our youth group at the time
that really had known the deeper truths of the Lord,
and they were striving and seeking
and abiding in him to know more.
It was a great example for me, uh, on our move to Woodward,
that's where I first met.
Cheryl, uh, met her at church at First Baptist.
My family was moving there from Oklahoma City.
Her family was coming to First Baptist Woodward from Fargo,
Oklahoma, where they had been at the Methodist Church
for a number of years before.
And we were both new at the same time.
And that's where we became high school sweethearts.
And I got to marry her later
after we were finishing our college
degrees at Oklahoma State.
Um, it was also at First Baptist Church where, uh,
there was a model of ministry
and a model of servanthood by one
or two people in the church that really, um,
solidified a calling for both Cheryl
and I to serve in the church.
And we've done so ever since from there to Stillwater,
uh, where we were at First Baptist Church for a number
of years in Stillwater, Oklahoma.
But there was another thing that happened in Stillwater
that was a conviction for me.
It was a conviction that even though I knew
that there were those that were striving
and really seeking to know the Lord in a deeper way,
that I didn't yet know
and appreciate the Lord in a way
that I could adequately articulate my faith in him.
Um, I wanted to go to Countryside Baptist Church,
little church just to the southwest of town in Stillwater.
Um, but it was known for having elders.
It was known for having a solid, uh,
theological, uh, background.
But one of the things I knew about joining, uh,
countryside at the time was that their elders required that
for membership, you were able to come to the elders
and articulate your faith and tell them what you believed.
And I, I was afraid I couldn't do it.
I knew I couldn't do it.
And it wasn't until several years later, uh, when we got
to Owosso after we got married, uh, that
the Lord grew in me, the ability
to know him in that deeper way.
Um, it wasn't until then that I knew, uh, how
to study the Bible, how to know about who he is,
but I'll tell you in just a minute
why it happened at Bethel.
And one of the things that I love
that I see still at Henderson Hills today,
but at Bethel, we, that was the point that Cheryl
and I first had our children, uh, Paige, Seth
and Anna were all three born while we were at
Bethel in Owosso.
And when we first got pregnant, unfortunately,
our first pregnancy was, uh, a miscarriage
and we didn't ever get to meet that child.
But one of the things that happened during
that time period was I was convicted
by Deuteronomy Chapter six.
I was convicted by the fact again, that I had a fear
that I was incapable of doing what Deuteronomy chapter six
told me to do, that I was
to teach while I was walking in the way.
And while we were sitting down and while we were eating
and while we were working, and I was needed to be able
to lead my family, to know the Lord
and to grow deeper in him, to serve him well,
and to minister to others, I, I knew I couldn't do it.
But one of the things that we had benefit
of while we were at Bethel Baptist Church was we had a group
of people, both men
and women that invested themselves in us,
that came alongside us and put their arm around us,
and they cared for us.
And they taught us, and they challenged us.
Uh, they were great community for us at that point in time.
We were about four, four
and a half hours away from all of our family, uh,
not very far in today's standards,
but still, it was far enough that the influence
that we had on a daily basis was not
so greatly our parents any longer,
but it was these people at Bethel Baptist Church
that invested in us in that way.
It was there that I knew why, that I knew inside
that I could not choose God.
Why, like Psalm 14, one through three that says,
the fool says in his heart, there is no God.
They are corrupt. They do abominable deeds.
There is none who does good.
The Lord looks down from heaven on the children of man
to see if there are any who understand, who seek after God.
They have all turned aside together.
They have become corrupt. There is none who does good.
No, not one in Jeremiah 17, nine that says,
the heart is deceitful above all things
and desperately wicked who can know it.
And finally, in Ephesians chapter two, where the, uh,
Paul starts the beginning of that chapter and says,
and you were dead in the trespasses
and sins in which you once walked following the course
of this world, I had been dead.
I could not raise myself back to life.
But now I knew in the scriptures why,
and I understood my assessment of good,
couldn't be people telling me that I was a good boy anymore.
My assessment of good had to be the standard of God,
which was much higher.
It was also in Ephesians just a little bit later, uh,
in chapter two, that I found out that for by grace,
you have been saved through faith.
And this is not your own doing,
but it is a gift of God, not of works,
lest any man should boast.
It wasn't something that I could work for,
it wasn't something I could do.
But God had given it to me as a gift.
And it was at this point at Bethel that I realized
what God had been doing in my life all along
because I could remember
and name people who had invested in me,
my parents, Robert
and Beverly Nall, my my in-Laws, uh, Roger and Judy Pruitt.
Um, um, people like Greek
and Denise s when we first came to Bethel, Cheryl
and I first came that day and we were greeted
and we were told where a community group was, uh,
Sunday School, I believe is
what we called them back in that day.
But, uh, we were led up to a stairwell at the back
of the building, uh, kind of over the pastor's offices
and looked a little shady at first.
But as we got up to the top of the stairs, I was greeted
by a familiar face, uh, Denise Vadas,
who had been a leader in the state student council.
And I had known her for a number of years,
not knowing at all that she lived in Owosso,
not knowing at all that she went to Bethel Baptist Church,
but finding out that she
and her husband Greek had led a Sunday school class
in the upstairs above the church offices
for a number of years before.
And we walked in, we were greeted with a face
that was kind and loving.
Um, we were also taught by Dr. Mrs. Cook.
We're also taught and led by Bill and Mary Stinson.
And we were taught and challenged by great deep Bible
teaching of a man, um, named Jim Wheeler.
It was during that time that we also found close peers, uh,
that some of whom, uh,
faithfully serve at Henderson Hills today.
Folks like Brian and Kathy Topping, uh, Darren
and Christie Lawson, Steven Elisa, er, uh,
Cameron and Jennifer Turner.
Cameron currently is an elder at Redemption
Church here in Edmond.
Uh, great friends of ours, Greg
and Shelly Cantrell, even Eric
and Courtney Harp that serve alongside
and with us in the college and young adult ministry
and are active in missions around the world.
These are just to name a few.
These men and their wives played an instrumental part in
encouraging and challenging me, my knowledge
and understanding of God.
These were the first who personally committed
to seeking the Lord and his righteousness,
and then leading me.
They were great examples, carefully committed
and devoted to exhibiting what faith
and ministry looks like.
This was also my first experience with being voluntold.
Uh, bill Stinson, uh, on Wednesday night had come to me.
We met in a back hallway at the church
as I was walking in to eat dinner.
And while I was walking in to eat dinner,
he asked if I would consider, uh, leading the third
and fourth grade Boys Awana class, uh, on Wednesday nights.
And I said, bill, I said, um, I, I don't think that
that's necessarily for me,
but I will pray that, uh, God will tell me if
that's a calling for me or not.
Another week or two went by
and Bill again, uh, found me in that same hallway at
that same time as I was walking to
that same meal on Wednesday night.
And Bill said, Hey, have you been praying about that?
What do you think? I'd love to get you, uh,
leading this class?
And I said, bill, I'm, I'm still praying about it.
I'm just not convinced that that is for me.
A couple weeks later, bill, uh, met me in that same hallway
for that same dinner and asked me that same question,
but he asked it in a different way this time.
He asked it by handing me and I want shirt and Awana books,
and telling me what time that I needed to be at
that Awana class to lead it,
and how long it would take for the Awana class that year.
That was a great thing for me
because what it did was it actually identified a gifting
that I have to teach and to lead others.
Um, something that was initially kind of seen in a third
and fourth grade boys, and then ultimately in the youth at
Bethel Baptist Church.
And then here as we've taught youth
and childrens at Hillside Kids, and as we teach
and lead a college
and young adult group in our home on Monday nights,
we still continue to follow that calling
that Bill Stinson identified in us.
And I very much appreciate that.
Um, all this time, God supplied opportunity for us
to know more about him, to teach
and lead others, uh, in his ways.
Um, here today, Cheryl
and I continue, uh, to be faithful to that commitment
that we made to serve
and to minister at the churches that we were at.
Uh, we are greeters, uh,
and connectors on Sunday morning in the gathering.
We are, uh, storytellers and hillside kids,
and we have that college and young adult group in our home.
And then I'm also a deacon at our church.
I have been since 2012
and been able to serve alongside a great number of men, uh,
who I, uh, really, really value their love
and, uh, ministries, uh, to our church as well.
Um, I need to round out this story though,
because I've shared a great deal about the number of fears
that I've had and the, the challenges
and, uh, convictions about, uh,
what I didn't know at times past
those children that I mentioned.
Paige, uh, Seth, Anna, and Olivia.
Today, Paige is married, uh, to a man named Scott Manning,
who is the countryside, uh, college, uh, young adult pastor.
Uh, they have two children in Stillwater.
Seth and his wife Devon live here in Edmond.
And they're, uh, active at, uh, Bridgeway.
Anna is now in Dallas and is at, uh, watermark
and Olivia, uh, attending Oklahoma State.
She still comes home almost every weekend
to be right here at Henderson Hills.
What I know from what God has done in my life is
that despite my fear, despite my lack of knowledge
and understanding when we first had children
and all of the convictions
that I had throughout my lifetime, God supplied
and continues to supply all we need.
He has never failed me.
He has always been there
and supplied even the things I didn't know I needed.
And he will continue to do that as we seek
to follow his calling in eldership.
He has proven and continues to prove
what Psalm 23 teaches us.
All. The Lord is my shepherd. I shall not want.
He makes me lie down in green pastures.
He leads me beside still waters. He restores my soul.
He leads me in paths of righteousness for his name's sake.
Even though I walk through the valley of the shadow
of death, I will fear no evil for you are with me.
You'll rod in your staff, they comfort me.
You prepare a table before me in the presence of my enemies,
and you anoint my head with oil.
My cup overflows.
Surely goodness and mercy will follow me all the days
of my life, and I shall dwell in the house of the Lord
forever.